guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to the
pregame
before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
okay a couple announcements before we
start the show the first being that we
have two clips channels that are up and
running so one is just pearly Clips
we're almost a 50k on that in a month
which is literally wild I I can't
believe the support that we have gotten
for this show
um the second thing is just is Pearl
daily
um the reason we do two different clips
channels is just to give
different editors a chance to like you
know show their different editing Styles
so if you want to see different types of
Clips Pearl daily just Pearl eclipse on
top of that we have four membership
tiers the first lets you be part of the
live chat today I decided to let
everybody in the live chat but normally
it's members only so um if you want to
be a part of the live chat on the
majority of shows join the five dollar
tier the 10 tier you guys get a first
look behind the scenes at the new pet
house yay
um thank you guys so much for the
support
um this is our first live back hopefully
that is successful we've had a lot of
problems with the move but I've had so
much support and just like help with all
the tech issues from you guys in the DMS
and I I really appreciate it because I
could not have gotten everything
together without the donations the
support and everything from you guys
um the third tier is going to be
connecting on social media and the
fourth tier is a one-on-one call with me
once a month on top of that go follow my
Instagram I'm almost a 50k on Instagram
which is just dot pearly things shout
out to our member of the week Dragon
stallion1001
um if you guys want to be a part of our
Members Only Live we do that once a
month we're probably gonna do that maybe
the 21st hopefully after we what we do
is we order a pizza after the show and
the staff we just answer questions and
you know do like a q a after the show
that's under the ten dollar tier if you
want to come on the show DM Eddie his
link is in the description so
um today I have a lovely panel so why
don't we go around everyone say your
name your age your relationship status
and a fun fact so you can start
hi my name is Linda I'm 20 years old I'm
single and with my brown skin and green
dress I look like a tree
hi guys my name is Bella I'm 26 I'm
single and a fun fact I love street art
hey guys I'm Dan I'm 27 and I have two
businesses
what are they one's in it and one is
helping guys level up in Fitness and
more so career self-improvement stuff
right now oh you should drop the drop
the name so they can find the name is
the geek physique
on pretty much everything yeah guys go
go follow he'll give you a good workout
plan
go ahead hi my name is Terry I'm 50.
um fun fact I've got a scooter
it's good hi my name is Marika I run
knows meows blockiana fun fact on
26. fun fact I am terrified of snails
why
I don't know why it just scares me if I
see you I'm gonna like ah just scream
I'm terrified everyone laugh at me but
yeah are you are you afraid of any other
animals or is it just snails it's just
snails but they want to have the small
case on top they're cute ones not this
light not these locks not the ugly ones
the cute ones they got this you know the
nice big case I'll just I'm scared of
them are gonna start crying
what do you think's gonna happen I don't
know I'm just scared if someone will
just show me I was like ah probably
start crying face
yeah fair enough you know I'm afraid of
I'm afraid of rats you guys have them
everywhere here too yeah I love them not
not in my apartment though
she's lying guys stop stop don't don't
scare me they got up here I would scream
okay um so today's topic um is can
Modern Men and modern women find Middle
Ground
um so my first question is I often hear
the term a modern relationship what is a
modern relationship to you
I believe it's dysfunctional okay tell
me why
because men and women are different
they're biologically different they were
made that way and so they have different
desires inherently of what they want and
the Modern Standard in my opinion just
doesn't work okay what do you think is a
modern relationship
uh it's a bit tricky to honestly you
know because it's hot
it depends okay age
also your
where you are as well background and
then also religion comes into it as well
so it kind of differs but I would say
modern relationships now I I would agree
with you Linda they're dysfunctional
unless you you're able to communicate
and stuff but it's hard to say this is a
modern relationship every relationship
is complicated yeah okay what do you
think of the modern relationship I would
agree with that where this below a
certain age
is
possibly dysfunctional because there
isn't defined roles and maybe there
isn't discussions up front about
you do this I do that you know
um and both of you picking up the slack
and doing your part and I think
some Modern relationships are
dysfunctional because
people don't communicate those
expectations up front
okay what do you think
[Music]
I think expectations
was a bit of a blurry line now nowadays
I think
Sometimes women
earn more they do more
sometimes men do the same so I think
sometimes it's not it's it's not it's
not as it used to be
um
before right
in a way
I think young people don't they don't
want it to be clear I think it's just
the way it is it's blurred that's an
interesting point yeah how is dating
changed over time
I think it was quite I don't know if it
was simpler meeting someone I think
nowadays it's harder to meet someone
although everyone does stay in online
but it seems harder still to
to drum up communication for someone to
speak to you people normally speak
um through texting yeah so people don't
although everyone's got inclusive
minutes they're still texting so that is
quite impersonal I find dating nowadays
and I think back in the day was they say
it was easy our people more
accommodating people more open I'm not
sure people that open now would you say
um because a common complaint I hear
from men is that women's standards are
too high would you say women's standards
have gotten higher over time or has it
always been like that
that unexp I think they're unrealistic
their expectations are unrealistic
so we a young person might say I'm just
going to say a young person might say I
want a guy who
I don't know drives he's got somewhere
to live and he should be earning XYZ
they want that for someone but they
don't really want that for themselves so
the guy has to level up but the girl
doesn't have to level up yeah she just
has to be available there would you
would you guys say that the dating apps
has exacerbated that progression so like
I feel like the dating apps skew that to
a large degree because like we have the
stats right where
only 20 of guys are seen as eligible
whereas I think in real life you might
chat to a guy you wouldn't swipe right
to
and there's that removal of like a human
element you know and the biggest things
for long-term relationship success
pretty much has nothing to do with your
looks
you know
um I would say that yeah it's made it
worse I don't I don't think social media
has made relationships better which is
interesting because we have more ways to
talk to people than ever but it seems
like we're more distant yeah it's weird
because like we before
um like I I had German nannies growing
up and it would be really hard to keep
in contact with them because of like you
know like Skype was kind of iffy and it
just it just was harder when I was
younger and now it's so easy but even
with all this technology it's like we'd
all talk less it seems like definitely
and people's social skills like after
all the craziness the last few years I
think everyone's social skills just took
a hit
and even people who claim to be
extroverted you know they would happily
say oh you know I have friends that were
more sociable than me in a way
and now they're just like happy to chill
at home and I think
I think you can actually set yourself
apart
like in previous experiences I've had
just going up to someone having a
conversation is almost unheard of now
that
obviously we can get into all the
expectations to get into a relationship
but just to open the door and speak to
someone I actually think is easier than
people would let themselves on
now initial attraction is obviously a
factor in that but I still think that
you can set yourself apart just by being
nice being interested in someone would
um would you girls agree like I I think
as a girl like
if a guy actually approaches you in
person I'm more likely to say yes than
if he like DMS me on Instagram or on a
dating app or something like to giving
him my number would you agree or
disagree depends I agree for sure I mean
I don't use dating apps I only go based
on person because
um like for me it's it's the aura that
they have it's the way they approach you
are they overtly sexual right away are
they asking interesting questions uh
what do they choose to ask about me sort
of thing and just it's it's easier to
kind of explore their mind on a dating
app if I didn't like how someone look I
could be swiping uh what's the direction
of your original left left I could be
rejecting like my future husband that I
have like so much in so much in common
intellectually and and values when guys
don't take good pictures I think in
general so I on this point I said
someone close to me swipe right on Five
Guys not that you find really
unattractive active but just you have a
kind of type but just bend the rules a
little bit swipe right on Five Guys and
just see where it goes just do it
because
you never know and
I think everyone that's been in a
relationship here I think could agree
that yes looks are important yes you
need to be attracted to your partner but
there is so much more
that everyone requires to stay in a
long-term commitment money
did you say money
decided yeah no I wanted to make a point
from the all because I didn't have a
chance I was about to ask you so I had
so many things I just wanted to say um
yeah as she said I feel like no
relationship are just mostly like super
like superficial and toxic but so the
fact that social media is there now so
obviously now everyone got a fake
expectation like not realistic
expectations because of what you see but
I was also how people what people showed
you now if a guy this always shows me
like Richard milley jury money big cars
approach me I am expecting living that
kind of Lifestyle now if I'm seeing you
and then you're just a normal guy having
a nine to five you're not entrepreneur
you don't own what you claim you own I'm
not gonna date you anymore because
you're lying so why would I date you
it's like me if I will go on my
Instagram and just Photoshop my pictures
like I got a big like nice body BBL big
everything now I'm going in a completely
a different person the guy will like why
you lie but at the same thing would you
say women are lying when they use
filters then I believe they got to the
point where they get so like insecure
but they look because they keep like
constantly like
compete with people that they see
they're not realistic beauty standards
if that makes sense like you cannot
compete for like a Kim Kardashian or
some Alexis sky for example and then I
don't really see the point on doing that
personally but um going back to the
dating thing I feel like it was really
really bad before especially after
covidia people don't they have like
social anxiety I see they've got any
more introvert because they got used to
stay home
but at the same time
I don't know I feel there's no like
there's no willing to communicate
anymore to be honest anymore not even to
personally uh I'm gonna be probably
unpopular opinion I like a guy they can
provide for me like they have actually a
good job stable job because as a man you
are actually meant to provide for the
woman you need to make me feel like I
can count on you if I want to open a
family I have a family right I can't be
with someone that got no job lose their
mom no money why would I do that but on
the same point I believe it got so toxic
to the level that you can't be like
honest anymore if that makes sense
because everyone lies a lot maybe thanks
to social media as well I don't know if
that makes sense so even the in-apps as
well as Cinder for example like it's too
probably over sexualized now so I used
it okay I used it and all this I'd like
to read about experience because guy
will just come up with you for the wrong
intentions like oh let's go out so I can
bring you back with me and it's not what
I'm you know what you look what I was
looking for at the time so that was
actually my next question
um who have you has been on a dating app
and what was your experience so why
don't you start okay mine was
I don't know it was probably it was
terrible okay so okay so this guy I mean
this guy it didn't really happen they
thank God didn't happen because this guy
was like a supermodel really good
looking guy and now I'm meeting this guy
that was back in Italy and I'm literally
down the road what are you wearing babe
and he's wearing something and this guy
was so ugly it was an old different
person right so you got catfished yeah I
was like sorry I cannot make it I just
literally run down the road see what men
go through every day
you will see me running down the road so
quick I was like I feel like I'm making
it running I was like speeding I was
like where are you I can see you going
somewhere I was like oh no that wasn't
me so it was so bad it was it was no it
was terrible since then I was like never
again
have you ever been on a dating app
how did that go okay mixed I mean
you know it's you can put your hand in a
bag and take it out and you'll get a
different response all the time but the
last time I went on one I mean I was
dating this guy for a period of time but
I friend zoned him quite quickly I mean
we didn't have
I wasn't attracted to him
and yeah there wasn't anything to him
he's a nice guy but just not for me but
you know I dated him for a period of
time but I mean one lesson that I
learned is don't friend zone them and if
they're not if they're just not how can
I say if you're not attracted to them
there's no point in being with them so
just just don't do it I mean I've
learned the hard way so yeah
yeah because I think sometimes it gives
people like mixed expectations although
they'll think like maybe someday and
you're like no no like never yeah and
and it kind of ends up hurting feelings
down the line because I'd hate if
someone did that to me yeah not only
that like you know
from quite early on I could see there
was
um we're not very compatible you know I
was good for going out going out
different places and I think he wanted
company I think that was the main thing
really and what he said to me was that
you know he wasn't very lucky on the
dating website so that told me that
you know I couldn't really get what he
wanted so was I second best did that
make him more undesirable because no one
wanted him no I think it was I don't
care yeah I think no it was more that we
didn't have much in common we didn't
have things that like interests me there
was no chemistry like I've got friends I
don't need her yeah was he too nice
I don't think any guy's ever too nice I
would disagree with that I disagree too
because I I used to be too nice so I've
been there myself what made you too nice
though yeah my mum my mum's one of the
nicest women I've ever met in my life
but she would never tell me that cold
hard truth so
[Music]
um
I had to learn the hard way and
a lot started to happen in my life in a
positive way
but I think a lot of nice guys
this is going off in a bit of a point
but they aren't as actually as nice as
they seem
and they are living lives of quiet
desperation so
you might think he's nice but actually
he could have some fire in him and he
needs something to wake that up
that's what I truly believe I think
because a lot of times you feel like
it's fake yeah if a guy's too nice
you're like what's the catch or or it's
it's like
I don't know how to put this but it's
like you you feel like they're kind of
they're scared to like actually go for
what they want so they're just like
chilling in the friend zone instead of
just like going for what they want and
it's like as girls we want the man to
lead
and I think actually
from being a recovering nice guy if you
like for anyone that's watching this
that feels like you're in that position
just wanting to improve is the step in
the right direction like I think correct
me if I'm wrong wrong ladies
but a guy on an opportunity rectory is
it is attractive right he might not be
exactly where you want him to be
but if he's honest to your point and
he's on an upward rise Fair place you
mate you'll you'll at least trying you
know I actually I have a question for
the girls would you guys prefer a guy
um
that is around your age but he's very
ambitious and he's going places or would
you rather have someone that's 10 15
years older and he's there someone on my
age and is going places okay so what do
you mean by he's there
um let's see career-wise so one guy has
a business he's successful one guy's
starting one and it could go either way
but he's very driven and you think you
think he's going somewhere it depends on
the they're both they're both marriage
minded both the same oh okay well the
older one then you'd pick the older why
um just because they have more
experience they're more wise and um
because they've had more experiences I
trust their ability to lead
um that's the main reason
yeah okay what why do you say no or the
younger one
for me it's like would be more on the
same page and that we can understand
each other a little bit more even though
if you if he's more of a leader I don't
mind because we're building something
together whereas if a guy is already
made it sometimes they kind of May
belittle you and just undermine you a
little bit and kind of control you
that's where the control could come in
to it as well as them being older as
well it's like therefore like they know
better than you so you don't really know
nothing whereas if you're some dating
somebody who's around the same age as
you is that you two are coming up
together and I'll say like a success
story for example like um
like nowadays women will go for a guy
that has money like okay that's their
preference by sometimes it's like guys
don't believe there's still women out
there that will go for a guy that's
still trying to make it as long as you
have ambition that is it if you're a guy
you don't have money and you have no
ambition then I can understand I
wouldn't really want to be with you
however if you have the ambition and the
drive and I can see that then why not by
all means we can make it together yeah
and you have something to back up that
ambition too yeah like yeah that that
makes sense yeah I think one of the
problems that I've got with that is that
women's if you are dating a guy who's
I cannot say if you're dating below okay
you normally make him a project and you
you kind of a woman might want him
they'll see the vision of him being a
bus driver but really as a cleaner so
they'll work on that when really they
should be working on themselves
and that's the problem that I have with
that like I've got my goddaughter you
know she if I say to her oh she's now 34
34.
um I think you'll be suited to someone
who's 37. she thinks oh that's too much
of a big man and I'm thinking that's
ideal for you not the guy that you've
just you know left the guy that you're
not with who was kind of relatively your
age but you had to kind of work on him
to be the person that he is today yeah
that took a lot of working hard you know
like disappointment and now she's not
with him so at the end of the day for me
I actually want to meet someone at a
higher level I don't want um a come up I
can't I just don't think that it will
suit me basically I haven't got the time
or patience for that uh what about when
you were younger would you have had the
same answer
I think when I was younger I didn't know
what I know now today and what do you
know now
self-love is very important is key and
also what's key is
where do you want to go in five years I
mean do you just want to be a girlfriend
for 10 years how many how many
girlfriends do you think you want to be
why not you know think more serious if
you think serious about your life you're
going to get serious outcomes do you
know what I mean yeah I think I started
old I started when I was 30. so I think
dating seriously dating dating going out
with men first experience 30. now if I
knew what I know now
it would be different you know I would
have married I wouldn't have divorced I
would have had my kids you know so it
would have been different when did you
get divorced I'm not divorced I thought
you said you would have gotten to we
would not I wouldn't have got divorced
but you wouldn't have gotten divorced
yeah so I said when did you get divorced
I didn't I haven't I what I what I said
was that I would not have been divorced
because I think I had quite Traditional
Values back then I wanted to be married
I wanted kids that kind of thing I think
I understand like I don't I don't think
that I would I think you would you know
if you had a different mind so you would
have probably married like and you would
be divorced by now what I meant was that
I would have married and that would have
been it I wouldn't have been thinking
about divorce because sometimes when
people get into relationships they think
that this is not gonna last so you were
you were scared of getting divorced so
yeah you're afraid to get married yeah
yeah but I would have done it I was so
confused yes can I just ask something
quickly about the the guy on a come up I
think there is a difference between a
guy that says he's gonna come up and
there's no proof in the pudding versus a
guy where you know what last year you
didn't even have a job now you've got a
job next year you've got a promotion
right he might not be there yet
but I guess going back to Pearl's
question what if he was on a genuine
come up like there was proof in the
pudding he wasn't just saying it can I
yeah okay talking from experience
it depends I feel like depends about how
the person that you are and where do you
want to go yourself because personally
now I'm really driven trying to open my
business I had two business with my
ex-boyfriend being together four years
blah blah let's do this together blah
blah blah perfect I wasted time
say that we build the two business
together now I'm leaving them and you
know when you do the meeting to draw
someone out
so you did so imagine like maybe you're
thinking now for what I want to achieve
in life because I'm there I want to open
my business you know I got a few like
business plan there already on the table
um waiting for
um some
investors to put some money in I would
love to have some money already that is
there because my ambition and my drive
once someone does already know that can
like help me out for the come up do you
know what I mean someone is working for
it it's not 100 sure but it depends on
the person that you are though I feel
like if you guys are really loving you
believe in each other like you know yeah
probably both of them but personally I
would be the older man that's really
there you'd be the older man yeah can I
just add on to what you said as well
um so when I say like if I want to date
a guy that's on the come up we have to
align so I know I'm dating you to marry
that's where the Common Ground will be
that's why communication will be key
also I'm not necessarily gonna give my
all to him we always have to have that
understanding that I need time for
myself to better myself also I'm not
gonna date somebody knowing that I still
need to work on myself I need to work on
myself first before I start dating and
when I do come when we do come together
it's like we can help each other in a
way where each other has helped us as a
woman I'm a Christian I understand that
the man is the leader he's the head and
then I'm the helper and I've got to
submit and not when people hear the
submission thing they think of it in the
wrong way when I say submit is just be
there for him respect him and support
what he says I'm the neck he wouldn't be
the head without me so I'm just as
important so we also have to like
communicate well and know that okay me
and you dating us for this purpose to
marry so I'm not playing about because
that's where I'm at at this stage of my
life I'm not just dating today so I'm
not going to date like five different
men because I don't have time for that
I'm working on me I'm working on my
business the same with him so as long as
we have that understanding that we are
dating to marry and he's going to come
up I'm on the come up then yeah it's all
about Community you said you're a
Christian how many people here are
Christian to show of hands would you say
that the church keeps people single not
necessarily it depends on where your
best and if you you kind of have to have
your own relationship with God as well
that's one thing about being in a good
church because some people you you just
listen to what the past is saying like
literally a fixated on him like they'll
worship Him you also have to have your
own relationship and understanding with
God the main role of the pasta is to
guide you and teach but also you also
have to have that own relationship with
God but they're there to help you give
those nuggets to you help you grow you
also have to grow within the faith
yourself okay that's what do you think
so I think so the Bible is very clear
that that God intends for Christians to
marry other Christians but uh
statistically speaking the church makes
up of
um 70 of of people in the church are
women
um and I think it's like 50 are single
women and there aren't as many uh at
least in the west like where I'm from
Canada the us there are not that many
guys in church so to answer your
question I think in some ways yes based
on the Bible
um yes unfortunately okay yeah I agree
with you
um you know Christian actually I was
raised Catholic okay
um and my mum and dad actually met at
church interestingly enough
but it was interesting when you said
about the pasta and I'm just thinking if
so many people are watching worshiping
him
and there's 70 if the stats are correct
as majority women wouldn't he be that
high value man that's kind of that's
right that's what I find like they take
like
I've heard stories on the show where
their Pastor will tell a girl not to
date someone because he's not like yoked
and not enough or Christian enough and
I'm just like okay well so the pastor's
keeping these girls single and that's
certainly and then but I just think like
results speak for themselves and if the
church wasn't keeping people single if
they weren't they didn't have some heart
to play and this men wouldn't be leaving
the church and women wouldn't be single
in the church if they were good at
building families but like I'll go to
because I grew up Catholic too and I've
gone to Christian Church too I've gone
to church here and I look around it's
like a bunch of single women yeah it is
it's true it is I'm really um happy that
you spoke about submission because they
actually don't talk about that in the
church they don't talk about what it
means to be a woman and what women offer
in relationships and what it means to be
a good wife and a good mom and a and
they don't talk about that at all so I'm
so happy that you you agree and they
also they also encourage men to take bad
deals yeah like and so off oftentimes
they'll encourage men to have this like
relationship with God be monogamous but
most of the girls in the church aren't
virgins so it's like you're telling them
to be equally yoked but most of these
girls are not virgins in the church and
why do why do Catholic school girls have
such a reputation and Christian School
girls do like two so I I agree with that
because I was I was raised Catholic and
I think where I was I'm not going to
speak for the whole Catholic faith but
we're from how I grew up it was
literally just a list of rules that you
just you just need to follow it because
this is what the word says and in some
ways that's true but it wasn't until I
stepped away from the faith for a short
period of time until I actually had the
context of why those rules are in place
God made you he knows you more than you
know yourself he knows every hair on
your head so he's just don't use them as
as God being evil and wanting to oppress
you because he made you he it's view it
as more like he made you and he knows
how you can find fulfillment and
happiness and freedom and avoid more
pain than there already is in life I I
agree with you
um but the one thing like I think they
they preach from a young age is they
tell girls like they'll have a happy
ever after no matter what they do
because they have these Catholic school
or not Catholic school they have these
Chastity speakers and I've seen
Christians I've seen Catholics and what
they'll do is like they'll be like oh I
was so broken and this girl like talks
about how she like basically she got ran
through and then still found a husband
and like okay that's good for you that
you found it but I can list 10 girls
that didn't happen for and if you make
those choices there might not be someone
to bail you out at the end of the day
and that's like more of an honest
conversation than I was so broken which
one isn't even true you were horny shut
up like stop and like it's not broken
when you just make a poor decision and
go ahead okay
and got decent popular opinion okay and
probably people hate me for this I was
raised Christian Catholic I don't
believe in the Bible I don't believe in
church I don't believe in but I believe
the majority of the people that blindly
follow these rules is people that have
been indoctrinated because that's what
the church does they found people that
are lost they are not they don't they
didn't find the faith on their self and
the law of God in their own ways so they
have to put all their faith in the hands
of someone else that is absolutely crazy
to me like I will never listen to
someone in church and I will blindly
just do it yes Pastor say this let me do
it that is why there's been so many
cases where the church
reunited all these people and the
pastors had complete 100 power and all
these people that believed because they
lost people they don't have their own
self-esteem enough to be like wait this
is wrong can I have an example I'm just
I'm like this is Broad so I'm just not
sure what we're an example would be
um even like even for girls to have all
these rules and in the Bible there was a
verse I think of maybe evangelo because
I don't know anything about you said
that what it was to like not sleep
around yeah they preach that for men too
yeah and they preach um yeah but not
really I remember I read this it was
saying the only purpose of a woman is to
fulfill and serve the desires of a man
something like that but that was the old
one right now I stopped believing church
because in my church it was people that
were claiming to be nases and racist and
just there look you know in the sense so
it's not the church I believe that
everyone can believe in God in their own
ways I do believe there's something
there but I don't I don't agree with
rules we church with everything because
we see the rules the pastors are the
worst people most most times at least in
Italy more time I do on the pedophiles
they went to jail
um
I think any position that's powerful
leads to corruption I don't think I
don't think the church is special and
I'm not like a die-hard like I'm not
acting agree to that like you don't
think that every position that that had
power in all of history has had
corruption like why do you think
politicians always get killed yeah it's
true
yeah because when you have power you're
like oh my God I can do this so then you
just do what do you think Genghis Khan
had like 100 like how many people are
related to him
man-made yeah I have a question for you
because you said something along the
lines of the rules and so
in the past right we've always kind of
had at least in the West in England in
the US and Canada we followed
judeo-christian values we our
governments have kind of implemented
have it there the Bible has inspired the
laws but recently over the last 60 years
we've deviated away from that do you
think that was a successful move given
the state of the world as it is
um
do you think people are happier do you
think they're more fulfilled do you
think they have the same level of
purpose as they did 60 years ago uh no
they don't because oh my God this is a
it's another complicated message because
before they used to have a lot of
discipline into that so they will they
will have a list of things they will
have to follow in order to be a good
father or degree a good wife and have
kids and a solid family and values that
we don't have anymore because it's too
much Freedom now so so then wouldn't
that kind of contradict what you said
like parent rules somewhat good yes okay
church-wise because you're saying in
general right I'm saying okay in um
General in the population I'm feeling
this now there's too many rules
everything's two three there's too much
Freedom now so people are getting more
weak you can always I feel like I'm into
Health people can do too much now I
don't have a guidance anymore but at the
same time church at least would want to
see in Italy I don't agree with that I
don't respect that because
Church always like have people believing
in that but most likely they they get
people that are lost they don't have any
they're easy to indoctrinate that's what
it to me personally that's what it is
because there's more like more a
worshiping type of thing more than
you're free to believe in what you want
and as long as you're a good person and
you're good with the other people as God
actually was saying right that's what
it's supposed to be about right but I
don't know I just don't like the church
and they were the past so they have to
get all these people there and more time
is just people that alone lost no
self-esteem crazy sad or yeah that's
great go ahead to be honest it's a
church it really is complicated things
it's a hospital you go there people
the reason why you you will see a lot of
people who are broken and hurt is
because that's where they're going to
heal for me what got me more connected
to church because I used to go to church
with my mom and so I'm just going for
the sake of grain with her I wasn't
getting anything from it like the word
like I'm hearing the part pastor
preached it just was I was not retaining
it I had to find God for my own self
find my own church I went from to
several churches but I wasn't
comfortable until I found the one that
I'm at now okay and being there hearing
the word it helped it healed me in a way
because when you do go to church you're
not going to go there perfect or
anything you're going to find a lot of
broken people and already if your mental
health is not 100 there you can't think
for yourself and you have a pastor that
is
not neces not necessarily teach him from
the Bible is adding his own knowledge to
it and kind of controlling the
congregation that's where it's bad but I
still believe there are good churches
there I'm at one now because they are
big on you knowing god for yourself
having that own relationship with God
and don't worship us you need to read
that Bible for yourself you may hear us
preach it's your own you have to take
that responsibility to go back do your
own research on that word that they've
preached and then yeah you can take it
from there don't let them control you so
I have a question do you think
um a lot of guys will talk about how
they really doubt like women in church
like the authenticity of them because
they happen to come to church at like 28
29 when times running out and they've
been ran through do you think that's a
fair critique not necessarily because
because it's like it's just kind of
convenient like right when you need a
husband now you're at church yeah like
yeah that's that's crazy now you're
sorry
it was wild I go to quite fairly a young
Church there's a lot of Youth there yeah
so there's different parts to a church
there's like the youth and then there's
yeah I understand there's different
parts I understand it's not everybody
but I've seen the trend I've seen like
like I talked to I've been to like many
different churches because I've moved
around a lot there's a trend it's like
between 26 ish to 35 yeah I can't speak
on that because my one is is quite a lot
of young people so I don't I can't speak
on that but I would say there's a lot of
people my age that have been ran through
like even me the reason for me going to
church is like I was living a lifestyle
that I wasn't happy with and I know that
I still got time on my hands because my
pastor does preach that he's just like
you can't expect to come to church at 35
where you should have changed their life
now so that's why it's important to know
God from a young age because it's like
you have different seasons and if you
miss one season it can set you back like
10 years do you think that keeps women
single though because they preach for
women to wait till they're married and
and you're basically saying telling like
you let the less guy hit it for free and
then you're saying oh you have to marry
me in order to have sex so you don't you
don't think and then like on top of that
there's only 30 maybe 20 men in the
church so it's not even and it's like
you're asking men to wait when you let
the last five guys go for free not
necessarily so it again it goes down to
you know and God for yourself having a
relationship with God and in that time
God will speak to you men will come to
you because you will be tempted I've
been in church and I'm not gonna lie and
say I was perfect I was still having sex
for quite some time whilst I was at
church that that's just because my inner
self was not ready but you're talking
about you so I'm talking from like a
man's point but so so what I'm saying is
honest I'm saying because that's one
thing and I I appreciate that like
that's that's but I'm saying like from a
guy's point of view like why would he
wait when the last guys got it for free
because men because men value Purity
that's why going to have somebody that's
on the same level as you so for example
now I know that I'm on this this journey
it's not 50 50. so I'm saying like there
aren't enough men in the church for the
women so like they're not you can't say
like oh we should all wait because
they're not there I'm not saying wait
because you can still go out and speak
to guys but you kind of have to use
discernment and know that okay I have to
go for a guy that's ready to wait for me
to get me so that's why you have to be
wise when you're dating but to me like
what I'm saying is like I think that
keeps women single because I don't think
there's a lot of guys that are willing
to do that because
I know but I think the the real thing is
like it's like you made your bed lie in
it and if you wanted if you want it I
mean it's if we want to live in a
fantasy world where all these guys are
dying to wait for born-again virgins but
they're not but they can't even get why
women will remain single because it's
that there's no hope like Thursday that
I was a hoe let me just continue being
on her then because there's no chance of
me getting a good guy
saying I think if you do go to church
and
you have been run through before
you know don't just put our blockers
because you've just started going to
church but
because I see your point right you've
waited so late in the day to change your
whole whole life and when I was helping
people online there was a lady that I
came across that over her name nameless
and she shared a whole past with me and
it was exactly what you're talking about
she had a really promiscuous past and
then she found God yeah and uh she
didn't she said to me I haven't been
with a man since and if I meet someone
I'll be with him but I see your point
because from a male perspective it does
feel like you're getting the wrong end
of the deal you know yeah because it's a
bad deal yeah and that's and the church
tells men to take that
a man in the church and so like on top
of that there's you're right there's
there's not the men there so even if we
had it all the girls or all the men got
married in the church like there could
still be 20 uh there'll still be what
like 40 of the women they're still
single that's why they date outside yeah
that's why they on a dating website and
live in a completely different life to
them going to church and that's what's
happening but if I'm a Christian and I'm
dating a guy I'm going to bring him to
church
and then if he is willing to come and I
can't I'll pray on it there'll be signs
where I'll see that okay this guy is
just trying to see if he can hit do you
get what I'm saying well but but all men
want to hit it that's like all men want
sex I I think there's actually like to
add on to this if there's any lady
watching this and she thinks church is
the answer I actually would flip on its
head and think
where a guy is going to be and where are
they going to be the most respectful
I've been in martial arts gyms my whole
life and I've never met a more
respectful set of men in my whole life
and they are predominantly filled with
men so to me it's like go create
leverage for yourself like it's funny so
I should join a martial arts gym yeah no
you should I'm I'm being serious and
they are
they can protect you right you know that
already because they're in a martial
arts gym they are the most respect some
of the most respectful guys you will
ever meet in your life you think they're
going to be violent in all of this they
are not they are the the some of the
least violent people I've ever met but
the the thing the thing is with the
church like they'll have a guy that has
all the qualities that a girl is looking
for but if he he says I don't want to go
to church I'm never going to go to
church they say to turn that down
and it's like okay well then die alone
like I see that that's the thing I find
hard about religion in general yeah is
the you could have almost the perfect
match but because they don't sign up to
your rules that you then you can't
um marry them and I think I think it's
one thing if you're a virgin like I
think you can ask more and you're like
more competitive in the church but it's
like if you if you're not like why would
a church guy date you yeah like it's not
in the Bible you can't judge another
person who are you to judge yeah but at
the end of the day like if you really
are in tune with God you can't judge
another person based off their lives
it was my weakness your weakness could
be something else I have to accept that
and understand that that was you that
was your past so that's another thing
that I noticed about now today's society
is that people are so fixated on
somebody's past that was my because
because you're looking at this from a
woman's point of view like when you
think you're thinking from a woman not a
man man care about a woman's past women
care about a man's future
so I'm saying like like they might not
they might say don't judge but I'm sorry
your actions say something about who you
are so so if I was with a guy that for
10 years was a drug dealer I'm sorry
it's not bad a bad thing to say hmm that
might not be a good husband and so if a
guy wants to say hey she was a hoe for
this many years like that's not going to
be a good wife I should go pick the
pretty virgin down the street like I
think that's fair I don't think that's
judgmental I just think that's your bed
um can I say something
if I had the past which I feel no one
should like be defined from you you have
past actions anyway no a guy that goes
to church should not follow the
judgmental mindset because everyone got
past but personally I would lie I was
like yes I'm a virgin I'll get surgery
down there and that's enough I would
never say that you would never find out
period
yeah but the thing is like guys aren't
dumb over a certain age like I'm sorry
if the girls come on like I've had girls
on the show and they're like 25 26 27
they're telling me they're virgin okay
yeah like come on like
um there's the occasional one I think
maybe but like you know your guy you're
like
yeah I mean
I like to think of myself as an honest
guy like there's one rule I'm almost too
truthful like my girlfriend's sitting
off camera and she would agree that I
I almost almost say the truth too much
because that's that's just the rules I
live by so
I would much rather just know the body
count and make a decision from there I
have certain standards Etc there's none
of your business though right you know
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
though yeah it is
yes it is it is because it shows to me
like a sense of self-value
um I think especially from a female like
from a male perspective like when you
meet a meet a girl
it shows to me a sense of self-value
because
I think everyone could agree here that
most guys
can sleep with someone and it could mean
nothing whereas with girls not every
time okay there's exceptions to the rule
but I think a lot of times it takes a
lot to get into that into that place
and
what are you getting from it like so why
are you shaking your head I know girls
that sleep with guys just because they
want to have sex yeah yeah same like a
guy can do it let me do it they're at
that point where I'm a hoe I've done it
yeah men and women are different and
understanding and so men have to have
women have a certain level of
requirements to sleep with a man because
some people say oh women have sex and
because it takes a lot more for women to
have sex but I've literally seen girls
that will sleep with men and feel no
type yeah but they don't they don't
start like that they do they don't they
don't know typically they're not
typically they don't typically they
don't typically start they they become
that but when they're 15 16 17 18
whenever they lose their virginity
they're not they don't they're not born
a Savage they're made because they've
just been and that's and that's why men
don't want girls that are ran through
because you you can't connect as much
the more people you slept with uh but I
grew up seeing girls sleeping around
I've seen it yeah so I saw it I grew up
in that Community that's why I can speak
okay and growing up I saw a lot of girls
and it was kind of like you had you had
girls who were known for giving head you
had this girl known for this like in
different areas there's a bunch of hoes
like a lot a lot a lot a lot so over
time things have changed things have
Society has actually changed
why isn't it why isn't it a man's
business to know your past because your
past dictates your future if you if you
have if you have it does if you have
habits your habits are who you are so if
you spent if you spent five years
sleeping around let's just say then how
how is he to know that you won't do that
again when you turn 32 like like because
you have that past like I'll give you an
example I used to drink okay in college
I drank and I decided to stop drinking I
don't drink anymore and the thing is
there's always a part of me that's going
to want to drink because I did it I
started it I used to really like it and
so it's like if you used to be a hoe
there's a part of you that's going to
want to go back no matter how much you
suppress it okay because you used to do
it a guy then as well a guy yeah I think
your habits like if a guy is sleeping
with everybody is it going to be hard
for him to stop yes but the thing is men
and women are different we value
different things girls don't care as
much if they get cheated on as as women
do they don't I'm sorry it's not the
same because then we wouldn't pick the
guys that cheat like I'm sorry we go for
the guys we go 100 of women want 20 of
men so if we're picking the guys that
are going to cheat there's there's one
out of three men that are virgins so go
pick them if you want to be a guy that's
faithful you are what you do yeah
but the thing is though to be honest
I've never heard well from friends and
stuff and our culture in UK is different
people don't really have a culture but a
guy would even leave you based on how
many people you've slept with do they
really care no no what age do they do
they know this is our age they care a
lot also they do care and one thing I
noticed you see with this whole body
kind of thing yeah girl's a lie there's
literally their body parts
I go to the extremes right I'll take a
polygraph test you take a polygraph test
let's go that's how committed I am like
that is the place
did you take a polygraph test
I'll take one you can ask me anything
anything okay I am fully committed what
happens when you hear something you do
not like what happens and you're already
in love with this girl like you you know
you want to marry her like would that be
the determining thing no and you know
that it was hard no no no I see what
you're saying I see what you're saying
for what what I was saying is when
you're in that first
um interaction yeah it depends on the
damage right it does depend on the
damage like if it's so much worse then
it's so much worse
but
I Believe In Truth like and it may be an
optimistic idealistic view of the world
but
I think you should be willing to put all
your cards on the table and I think the
truth comes out eventually Maybe not
today maybe not today maybe not tomorrow
but like if you've been sleeping around
town he's gonna he's gonna run into
someone you slept with exactly so so
like you're right women I do see hoes
get wiped all the time I I do see it and
a lot of times the men don't know but
the truth comes out or they leave
because they're too damaged are there
some who have been to so okay let me
just say this now there's no win-win
then for her it's Eva you tell the truth
you like the guy will leave you and then
you try going the straight and narrow
you've been literally celibate let's say
five years and that's not your lifestyle
it could also be it could be it could be
to lower your standards and think Hmm
you know I'm not a virgin so maybe I
could date outside of the church and he
doesn't have to be equally yoked because
how yoked am I if I'm not if I'm not a
virgin anymore
they do work they they date outside of
the church and they're going out with
um say ghetto guys they're going out of
guys who are proper hardcore you know
what I mean don't believe in no church
they believe in Saturday night I'm going
out raving that's what they believe in
so so they'll be in the church and
dating the guy yeah the the but he's not
a husband right
it's just the way you told the story
that's the way no no he wouldn't be
husband material okay but then again
they might want him to be husband
material he might be really good in bed
and you know good in bed might qualify
him to be you know he he might be able
to do to make me happy I've I've just
found there are a lot of the women in
the church have too high of Standards
because they aren't what men value
anymore
and so I just I've just found a lot of
like 27 28 29 to 35 year olds that
aren't virgins requiring a man that's
equally yoked and I think that's a tough
ask and I think if we want to build
families like that's going to be tough
that's going to be hard so people can't
change then
China they just have to lower their
standards that's that's all as long as
they lower their standards I think
that's fine I think it also women can do
that very well lowering the standards I
think I think if that was true then
fifty percent of women that hit 30
wouldn't be single and childless because
one again one out of three men are
virgins the men are there that want to
commit so women women
um on dating apps they only swipe right
five percent of the time so that that's
telling me that we don't in fact lower
our standards I think on the body count
thing and so to your point right I think
you have to be realistic you have to
know where you're at and I think
if you come in with a realistic View and
an open conversation you at least
increases the chance of speaking truth
right but I'm not saying it business
though that to me is so crazy like so
you meet a girl for the first time right
what's your name nice to meet you how
much how many guys use let me know so if
if we're dating and then we're things
are getting more and more serious
I guess I would put it another way right
let's say the goal is taking all the
boxes for you not perfect but a lot of
the boxes
and you have a like you have a suspicion
and you don't want to ruin it maybe you
remain ignorant maybe if you don't want
to ruin it for yourself and everything
else is great then maybe we're in an
Inca room but I think what Pearl said is
really
true because sometimes their friends
will come out you know you're all you're
a mate of a mate will know her say
something like I feel like she started
dating someone because the way you put
it down is more like tell me everything
of everything about you already it's a
bit too much to chill so obviously if
you study you know you ask her you know
I kind of hear that you've been with
these guys
sure maybe the girl will say yes and
then from that on like she said the
truth eventually will come out yes but
it normally wouldn't be your business
I am today and guys children judging
anyway girls have been quite honest with
me in the past like they've been open
with me they've opened that conversation
quite a few times more than I have so if
they open that conversation with me then
I at least give them the benefit of the
doubt and say like
are you trying to pull the wall over my
eyes and sometimes it's been
more than I'd like but then I've I've
thought
there's
there's good things here yeah and I
think no like it goes back to the high
value man thing right it depends on how
much leverage you have in life how many
options do you really have because if
you want I guess it comes down to this
if you want uh to be with someone
marriage kids whatever if you want to be
with someone
there are compromises you're gonna have
to make so if you don't have many other
options on the table and she brings a
lot to the table then
give her a shot you know so I have a
question for you so
um when they take a girl that's a virgin
um they they come back to her in 10
years and ask if she's happily married
if she's a virgin she has an 80 chance
of a happy marriage if she slept with
more than five people it drops to
30 percent
knowing that information don't you think
men should judge because wouldn't you
rather take the girl that's an 80 chance
versus a 30. wouldn't that be a better
bet that's inside the church no that's
not that's just women that's so they
surveyed women they said how many people
did you sleep with then in 10 in 10
years they came back to see if they were
happily married the virgin's 80 chance
they were happily married
um outside of that 30 chance
yeah of course but that's that's facts
because of course if I'm ignorant and I
never like known sex as also
um can you do someone you you know you
get to know your sexuality so can I can
I just get a yes or no would you say
they should judge that knowing that
information because you said before they
shouldn't judge but now that you know
information that virgins are better the
less people you sleep with is better
would you say men have a right to judge
because they want better outcomes no one
is allowed to charge anyone to be honest
plus that's why I believe no one is like
okay
maybe maybe maybe let's not say judge
let's say be discriminate be picky with
who they date and not date the host they
will rather obviously of course go with
someone that's more conservative virgin
so he's like oh well perfect but their
happiness in the marriage will come from
ignorance as soon as you start learning
sexuality then you decide what you want
to do with that but personally I feel
like no one should judge anyway because
the guys are known they're No Angels
they're not saying I understand we point
to me I'll see what you mean though
because obviously you get I'm not saying
the more people you zip we've got more
maybe expectation and also
um I feel like lava relationship is
something that should add on to your
life not something that you need or
you're looking for that's why maybe so
many girls are like oh my God I can't
find it because you're looking for it
too much you're too desperate for it so
that's why maybe maybe judge isn't the
right word but you do agree they can be
selective and not date the girls that
have slept around like you think that's
fine
yeah I mean of course why is it why is
it a problem to be like ignorant of of
how other men are sexually like I'm
looking forward to to being with my
future husband I've never had sex but
I'm looking I'm looking forward to just
being with him and I don't want to be
with anyone else but remember why is it
bad that I'm gonna be ignorant of how
other men are it's kind of like
objectifying them no it's not bad it's
facts because if I
um let's say I've never had sex before
and now I'm getting married I don't have
sex just after I was gonna have sex when
I get married right now you don't know
sex you get into learn sex with your
husband now if you only have one person
throughout your whole life of course
there's more chance that if you've been
happy you don't know nothing else no
maybe you're gonna cheat one day and
these guys Bell so what are you gonna do
yeah no because in in my eyes he's the
best I'll ever have
like I I hope I don't have anyone to
compare him to so why why is it a
problem I'm gonna be happy either way
well I've been cheered on and I'm
perfect so
no I'm joking I'm joking guys but I'll
see you I see your point of view but
I don't know life is strange it can be
many situations where maybe there
because women's will cheat more because
of the mental connections more than the
physical guys will go for like I'm
feeling that maybe my wife's tonight
should go that she got a headache she's
not gonna be deep she's not gonna sleep
with me now a guy will go and cheat a
woman needs more like maybe their mental
connections more to cheat I think
honestly especially but you never know
in life maybe you're going to cheat on
someone that's better than your husband
no you said no I wasn't shaking my head
at that I was shaking if they had of
like a girl not having sex with you like
if I'm making a guy wait until marriage
I'm gonna have sex with him whenever he
wants no I don't I don't think that's
that's not the point like if you want to
wait it's you have all the rights away
and you should find someone who's
willing to wait for you you shouldn't be
like make you feel guilty for you to not
want to enjoy having sex but obviously
if you if you guys stay in or if um girl
is a virgin and then 10 years later then
happily marriage of course because sex
is you know is a big values of it so of
course if I'm having a lot of options
but but you don't know nothing because
you like your virgin right for example
there's more chance it's going to be
happy later like that's my point I don't
know if okay yeah so that's like
preferable like the men should go for
the virgins if they can yeah of course
yeah they will but they have this uh
Superman type of like ego that they
should like kind of like sit down and
yeah I would say I would I would say
that most men don't have a super
um super ego I'd say most women are
pretty narcissistic because most women
think that they're tense
um and just things like that like I'm
special like most women think they're
special I think that's social media as
well yeah increase that a lot because
now you see people that just don't know
I think they like Beyonce you're like
yeah
it's dating apps as well because if if
loads of guys are going to swipe on you
you don't know what you don't know you
might value that you look at that it's
like that little dopamine here oh I've
got 10 matches today you don't even want
to speak to any of them but it makes you
feel good it makes you feel like more
than you are you know
um that was actually
my next oh wait I think some people
didn't actually answer the dating app
question so what as a guy what has your
experience been on dating apps so
sitting behind the camera off camera is
my girlfriend we met on a dating app but
there is a bit more to the story so
obviously girls don't set their radius
very big because they don't need to
she uh lived outside of London we went
to the same comedy gig in London Hodge
twins Gig if anyone knows the hot swings
oh my God they're in London yeah a while
ago I don't know if they'll come back
hopefully they will
um and so we match through that and then
we well I was messing around a bit
because I came out of a relationship and
then we actually ended up getting back
together because we were seeing each
other for a bit first
but after seeing other people it just I
didn't want to didn't want to see
anybody anybody else so and what what
made her stand out from the other girls
she made me laugh one thing which was
big is she made me laugh she had jokes
oh my God she's genuinely kind
um I met her
I met her mum and I met some of her
family and meeting them I think meeting
someone's family or someone they're
related to tells you a lot about that
person how they were raised
and that's really important
I was also very honest with her about my
past
and I think that opened the door because
going back to the honesty thing I think
if someone shares you with you something
that you would not be proud of I think
it's actually a green check mark to say
why would you tell me that like you
wouldn't lie about that right so that at
least leans me towards well you must be
at least being a bit honest with me
and that means meant a lot to me and
another thing was
I think we didn't even talk about all of
this stuff like gender roles and all of
this sort of thing but
she would always always say to me that I
was different to the guys that she'd
dated before and I've always been
ambitious
and
I like to I like girls who who like
ambition and um yeah I guess it's just
like I I was you know we went to see
other people and it was just boring and
it wasn't wasn't what I wanted so
I went running back I'll admit it so you
went to the streets and you were like no
no I was like get out of here
but just very quickly on that I think
for guys a lot of the fun is in the
chase
and once you once the chase is over
it's then okay but you have to spend
time with that person you know yeah yeah
so yeah
and what um for the girls what would
make a guy stand out to you or if I
can't remember who if any of you were in
relationships but if you are to say what
made your partner stand out go ahead for
me the number one thing is values we
have to have common values because for
me as I've mentioned I'm looking for
marriage and I think the foundation of
marriage is to have common values you're
raising kids with this person so values
work ethic intellect and just their
decision-making ability because I
believe in submission and marriage that
was another thing actually so one thing
I really respected is she was so good
with her finances I know it seems like a
weird thing but to me that's Rose
responsibility you know
um and common values like we talked
about a lot of that stuff and you know
do you want kids yes you know that sort
of stuff I think that's really important
definitely
what about you
um yeah values is a big film for me as
well and also just like just knowing the
little things that make me happy because
I dated a guy where he felt like taking
me to like these nice restaurants and
everything would was impressing me but I
like to go to the cinema I like going
for walks like I like little things like
that like just buy me my favorite sweet
make me laugh at accepting me for me as
well
um that would make me go for a guy like
a family orientated guy as well a guy
that can make me laugh I like to laugh
I'm a joker so somebody that understands
me as well for me and yeah that's what
I'd
I was just thinking
um that my ex was quite open he would
tell me
um who he's had relations with and
quite accommodating
um very kind would look at the small
things like oh you like sherbet I'm
gonna buy you that but the flip side to
that is that I found that he wasn't
exactly who he wanted me to believe he
was but thinking back you know he was
that type of person and although I'm not
with him there are you know I look back
and I think oh you had good fat there
was some good things about you as a
person although he was disingenuous but
why didn't it work out was it because of
that
um now I found out
um
the truth about the person so yeah it
wasn't what he wanted me to believe
basically yeah can I ask you something
all the ladies here if let's say um
you're speaking to a guy right
and
he asked for a girl's number in a bar
but he doesn't chat to her he just
flexes to see that he's still got it
right but he tells you he comes to you
and he goes I asked for this girl's
number
I didn't even call her but I just wanted
to do a CR still got it I'm coming to
tell you this to show you as like a
commitment to show you that I'm telling
you the truth would you stay with that
person as much but I'll still stay with
him would you stay with him yeah I'll
just mash the phone what and and why
would you would you value that him
coming to you and telling you that or
would it no okay
um what's the point is that why are you
trying to prove that you still have it
you've got me yeah but I guess we toxic
so so would you leave him then oh do you
check him I don't like we'll go down to
the root of it we'll talk why did you
feel like you needed to do that what are
you trying to prove are you doing that
my thing is communication and honesty
I'd rather you come to me if the truth
hurts but it hurts I'd rather hear the
truth than I lie so then he told you the
truth
that's why I'm saying communication like
I'll communicate with you like why did
you feel like you had to prove that you
still have it why but like you kind of
are explaining why men lie because if
they tell you the truth they still get a
headache yeah yeah then we get over it
no no I know but like we can't forget
that's for you like like you guys don't
want to talk they're like oh I told you
the truth do I get upstairs and you're
like no we gotta talk about no we'll
talk about it but like we'll resolve it
we can move on but that's not the reason
for me to like leave you especially if
we're married is that what you're
talking about just it's just a
relationship in a relationship yeah just
well kind of like yeah oh look at it
like but this is a solution we have to
resolve kind of thing okay you probably
wouldn't it sounds like you wouldn't
understand the reason why he would want
to do that anyway I'll try to understand
it that's why I'm saying that we'll
communicate we'll talk we'll sit down
and have that conversation that I'll try
to understand it and if it's something
me and you need to work on together then
we'll do it and then move on with the
relationship it's something so am I new
if it's something that I know I can't
get over then yeah I'll probably leave
him but for something what about you I
mean I I'm not thinking too deep into it
I just think it's strange like like if I
if I go let's just say I'm walking down
the street and a guy approaches me and
tries to chat me up I wouldn't go tell
my partner that I mean if he's with me
he knows that you know people people can
be like would be interested in me but
I'm talking about the reverse so and the
reason it may happen is go you girls get
approached all the time right but guys
don't get approached as often not really
ever unless you're top top or you're
really good looking whatever right
so what if he's just flexing to know
that he's still got it that's it it
might seem pathetic to you okay yeah it
kind of does but if he wants a reaction
from you you think he wants a reaction
what if he wants to what if he wants to
show that
um he's he's desired he's wanted yeah I
feel like if he actually like was
desired though then he wouldn't need to
flex it exactly exactly not necessarily
guys are weird not necessarily because
because you you are coming from a
position of you always have options
available to you right so even if we are
in a relationship you always know you've
still got it yes or no
yes so for a guy
he may like I guess what I'm saying is
would you rather a guy that just goes
and cheats and tells you or he just sees
that he's still got it because I tell
you for a while you might think this is
a weird thing but when I was when I used
to work for this company I won't say the
company
um one of the bosses would tell me he'd
say yeah I chat skills all the time and
like I like I'll chat them up on that
but I just do it to know that I've still
got it because I like that chase
and my wife kind of likes it he said
like his wife coach so they'll go out
and shields spot him doing it and like
she'll get the hots for him because it's
kind of like she knows he's still got it
yeah I know it sounds really weird but
he he always sees her getting attention
right so it's kind of that reverse to
say like
well what if you never see your man
getting attention I understand I think
you see what I'm saying because then you
know he's desirable yeah but I think
like if I witnessed it myself if like if
I was with somebody and I witnessed like
a girl kind of coming onto him a bit
yeah I would I would be like that's
that's hot but for him to come to me and
be like oh you know I got all this
attention that just that's that to me
it's it comes off as beta it's kind of
like it's kind of like a guy trying to
like Flex his money be like oh you know
like I made
um x amount of money last week it's so
cool it's like it's weird I just think
it's weird I look at it like this that
today okay I'm gonna look at it like oh
okay babe yeah you've got some attention
long term I don't think I'm gonna look
at it like that I'm gonna think this guy
needs a lot of validation it's long time
no I would just don't tell me I'm good
like I'm like I See No Evil Hear No Evil
okay I don't I don't want to know
um I'm gonna take a second I'm going
Read Super chats guys thank you so much
for the super chats we are trying to get
two more cameras in here that is um the
next thing that we are saving for so
we'd like to get one maybe like the back
of the room and then one
um we're blessing where do we want to
put the sixth one
what put song in the mic
I call it close up one okay
um okay
um osmosis reacts um pearls Mike is
peaking osmosis reacts um why would a a
guy feel the need to tell her
um 90 free Tope women are too dumb for
hypotheticals
big Breezy um the girl in the green
leggings needs to stop telling men what
we should and shouldn't judge we don't
want a wife
um tfl London bikes FFF she's giving off
big big bike energy right now Darius
Horton
I should ask the woman guest if they've
had a son would they want their son to
marry a woman with a promiscuous past
um Alistar Horton if both genders didn't
judge there wouldn't be any so if both
genders didn't judge there wouldn't be
so many singles in the dating Market
Manny F the woman said not to judge a
person based on their past would they
date a person that had a cheating past
Larry Nelms the body count men are
willing to accept is different based on
the man Marco woman in the green is an
absolute 304. anyone that's that
defensive about their past is for the
street and We Know It mgtail by Logic
it's none of your business always said
by a greedy low-value classless woman
who wants it all and F what a man wants
drazian gaming imagine dating someone or
marrying or marrying the green one 93
Tope women lower their expectations not
their standards big Breezy I'm from the
UK yes all of us men care it's the most
important thing we just won't tell you
that you're not serious if we think
you're a bike drazian gaming girl stop
gaslighting please you're being too
dramatic drazian gaming noticed how they
jumped on his neck when he gave his own
opinion why are you judging him based on
his opinion you hypocrite Eric bites if
rules are needed which of the rules are
you going to adopt if the Bible and why
is that system better living in a
Biblical culture is healthy for everyone
even non-christians big Breezy cardi B
doing the most five years ago busting it
down for the madman and libertine now
cardi want want be cardi wannabe
representing na because I'm a power
lifter but even I couldn't bench certain
girls body counts these days
um Burley here do not judge lest you be
judged for with the Judgment you
pronounced will be judged and with the
measure you use it for will be measured
to you fixed it for you drazian gaming
to the sister in the black please review
this live and read some of the comments
you're all over the place mgtow by Logic
I can judge how dare you judge my right
to judge ma'am mgtow by Logic being a
reformed 304 is better than not being
reformed reforming doesn't delete your
past men deserve to know the truth so
they can make an informed choice about
her Geo um becoming my best self after
meeting my boyfriend with his motivation
this channel really finished red pilling
me hard starting started as a feminist
whale to losing 50 pounds let's go 50
pounds
feminine and happily submissive thank
you uh look at see they can't say my
whale jokes have done nothing they can't
okay see brown
um so we're waiting on a used up snatch
up Matt butcher um feminism no fault
divorce welfare state birth control
abortion laws at all the same time
disrupted and deluded the family Dynamic
for over two generations will it take
two generations for us to learn from our
mistakes the UK Economist please ask
your guests if an experienced bride
should still wear a white dress really
quick should just yes or no yes don't
don't should a girl wear a white dress
if she's not a virgin yes or no she
shouldn't
I don't give a heck
I don't care you don't care no no no
see I'm torn because I feel like you
shouldn't but I I think I'm still gonna
um Larry now I'm thinking for the super
chat um
Hamza Yasmin
um the that is the problem with today's
society they put the blame on
expectations on exceptions rules and
other things it's about taking
responsibility for what you've done
yourself and you blame it on others Max
Q rello can shorty with the mask show
her face she looks bad as F uh marriage
causes divorce any UK guys do not get
married divorce judges are crazy you
will lose around 70 if there are kids
involved you will be left with about 30
percent Middle Ground is to cohabitate
speaking speak to divorced guys before
getting married
um be easy 716 men leave churches
because women have become the leaders by
the Bible standards women can't Pastor
they are supposed to teach the next
generation of women to be wives many
churches are out of order mgtow by Logic
a lot of women in the church were in the
club the night before so dot dot dot
yeah row Church no hey Pearl Phantom
Watcher here Janice fi yingo On Studio B
YouTube channel has been doing an expose
on conjunctions of feminism for the past
several months check it out she also did
an interview with Jordan Peterson's wife
kellyanne Daniel's success story keep
the house clean make dinner love your
husband also Fitness being inspirational
and submitting to your husband is a
success story let him lead big Breezy
LOL the girl in the green dress in the
face is covering a jewel word word word
word word Scotty mcdump waffle no the
modern Elite structure is overwhelming
so overwhelmingly support feminism and
naturally women want to capitalize it so
why would they ever compromise
you like no we can't find Middle Ground
nor should we objective truth is real
and the hubris of society modernity
needs to be rejected mgtow by Logic
every relation is as complicated as the
woman chooses to make it me love gorto's
Channel thank you for the super chat
um kill on Daniel's Pearl I'm here to
catch my first live hope all is going
well please leave a bowl of milk for the
cats cat ladies next time okay
um so question
I'm going to read an article so since
the start of the 21st century the U.S
marriage rates has the I know we're in
the UK but I used the U.S one the U.S
marriage rate has declined for more than
eight marriages per 1000 down to six
marriages per 1000 population in 2019.
the marriage rate is the lowest level
since the U.S government began keeping
marriage records for the country in
1867.
why aren't people getting married
anymore
because women don't know what men want
in marriage and the standard for men has
been the same and so
women also don't really know their
nature either so they kind of they
expect a lot from men when realistically
it's not really possible given the state
of like the economy because in the past
in the 1950s and and before that
like it was it was okay to be
hypergamous in a way because women
didn't really have much money so if a
guy makes I don't I don't know like by
those standards 30k a year that was fine
because they they were they were still
living with their parents but now like
women actually out earn men in many in
in certain industry I'm not sure but I
know that they go to college more than
than men do and so they want a man
that's more educated they want a man
that makes more money and like
realistically given their nature that
makes sense get due to history but it
doesn't make sense now because men and
women are competing and their standards
aren't lowering mm-hmm
what do you think
um
we're sorry my mind went somewhere else
can you repeat the question yeah why um
so marriage rates are lower than they've
ever been why aren't people getting
married anymore
um I'll say Society now in a high
expectations
um I would say social media also like um
back in the day kind of a thing where
there's a lot of cheating nowadays
people are easily swayed both men and
women and I'll say social media plays a
big part now like Instagram and stuff
like that
um also now a lot of people know they're
worth I would say kind of them they
won't settle for just you beating me up
and stuff like that whereas back in the
day a lot of people would like they'll
compromise and stay but I know I'll say
some a lot of people know their value
yeah and more work kind of thing you
think people know their value yeah
sometimes yeah I agree I think that's I
think when no not the value part I I
agree I think the reason why men and
women aren't getting married anymore is
because of wokism yeah yeah I think
it'll work yeah okay go ahead I think
that's a big part of it and I also I
think it's a few things people don't
really know their roles and they don't
discuss that up front so when it doesn't
work out for them either way for the for
the Lady or the man
they they almost feel resentful and then
they they divorce and they think the
grass is going to be greener I think the
grass is grass is greener syndrome is
legitimately a thing it comes from like
social media and dating apps and
people have never had to commit like
they have to commit now because they
have so many options now yeah so I think
if you can commit now it says a lot more
than back in the day because back in the
day
you only really knew who was around you
in your town do you know what I mean you
couldn't if you're a baddie you know you
could get flown out to somewhere that
stuff like that just didn't happen you
know so
um for you because you've actually
um
seen dating change I'm sure over the
past like 20 30 years why did more
people get married before and why don't
they get married now
I think there was more stigma you
couldn't have kids outside of marriage
and it's for it to be okay I think
that's one thing and I think there was a
lot of pressure from families for you to
do the right thing nowadays you can
cohabitate for years you can have
children
in that in that partnership and not
really have stability although you might
think it's stability you might have been
with the same person for 10 years
but I think
um I don't see that as stability really
because a lot of people leave
relationships they go into another one
they create another family so I think
values have changed what people see as
the norm now has changed cohabitating is
the norm and even people that I know say
they would never think about marriage
they'll think about living with someone
but not marriage as the ultimate
commitment but my parents married that's
what I would look look to do because I
think it's the right thing for me even
though you know I'm at the age that I am
I still think it's it's the right thing
to do
do you think marriage a marriage is a
bad deal for men nowadays now that we
offer less than ever as women so the
average age of first marriage in the UK
is 31 so we don't have youth anymore
um Purity like I think most men would
pray for a girl with less than five
bodies nowadays uh where they used to
get virgins and on top of that the
divorce laws are very heavily favored
towards women where we can leave and
take half and there's you know sayings
like it's cheaper to keep her on top of
that if we leave we can also take the
kids and put them on child support
um would you say that if that marriage
is a bad deal for men today why would
they get married I said depending on who
you're marrying it'll be a bad deal
okay I think by and large you're you're
spot on with a lot of those points I
think one of the biggest ones is just
the the divorce because a lot of things
have been equalized for better for worst
why has that not reflected those things
and the divorce laws yeah yeah because
if they were
and I I'm speaking from someone who I
actually want to get married you know
and I think if you're a guy and you want
to get married maybe prenup might be a
good idea if you are if you are of some
high amount of value
but I think it's an even bigger
sacrifice for a guy to make now than
ever before but because of that reason
like you could be in a relationship the
goal earns as much as you're more and
then your divorce and they get even more
right so it's I think that is I think
one of the biggest factors what would
you say
um so one why do you still want to get
married even with all of that and to
what would you say
um would you say a prenup is the
solution or are there other solutions
that you could think of from a guy's
point of view so I'd say prenup is part
of the solution and I'd also say that
um I like the idea of making a sacrifice
um I think a lot of the best things in
life come with sacrifices
and
also my mum and dad had me quite late in
life so they're kind of everyone I went
to school with their parents were
younger so they're an older generation
and I guess I maybe I'm a hopeless
romantic you know the the comments
section can rinse me for it I don't I
don't care but
I do yeah yeah they will yeah I'm sure
they I'm sure they will but I think
I'm confident in myself enough to still
Flex you know like Brendan Fraser if you
know the actor he had one of the worst
divorces ever I don't know all the
details
but he's just come out with some amazing
movie right he's still flexing because
he knows he's still got it and I think
that shows confidence as a man that if
you can still make that sacrifice and
you can still earn after
you know do you think another solution
is just living together and never
getting married potentially yeah yeah I
think
I think kids in my opinion is the
ultimate commitment and then marriage
after that because you'll essentially
make you're passing your genes on with
someone else you're choosing to mix your
genes with someone but
yeah I think cohabitation is a solution
you know it's also a crazy thing is that
um men I don't think women really
appreciate how much of a sacrifice it is
for men to get married
um because one in four marriages are
sexless
um so it's like men go through all of
this stuff to get married and girls
won't even say that sex is you do but
rare like girls won't even admit that
sex is a duty like they don't even get
sex whenever they want yeah I think
again
I think a lot of people again I'm not
saying I'm perfect but that's why I
think truth is so important because if
you go into something saying these are
our roles this is what I expect from you
what do you expect from me and I'll say
okay I'll put a ring on it as long as
these things are in place if these
things are not in place no longer then
it's those are why we're divorce okay
um what about you guys what incentive do
you think men have to get married today
culturally though I mean our culture we
we have we still governed under our own
choices like I know Africans and some
Caribbeans Africans more they are gonna
marry they're not going to think about
doing prenups they're going to get
married
even if they had children outside of the
marriages they're still gonna get
married Caribbeans I'm not sure really
if we're kind of into getting married I
don't know when's the last time I went
to a wedding but like from an African
point of view yes they still get married
I just think that um
people not traditional people are
untraditional and it's for the kids
right I think a lot of people in this
day and age think that they forget that
what is the function of marriage
I believe it's for the children you know
it's both of you saying till death do us
part and if you actually take the words
you say seriously which I don't think
I always I always think about that women
from the 1940s and 50s would like laugh
at us today because like they'd be like
oh you left because you weren't happy my
man had a whole family across town and I
stayed you know what I mean like that
used to happen like families would meet
at funerals and even
um you know I have some relatives that
like kind of you know stayed together
through cheating and like all this stuff
but like nowadays like girls will just
leave because they're not happy which is
which is crazy especially when you have
kids it's not about you it's so crazy
and that's why I don't think men have
any incentive anymore to get married
like because
initially men would marry for sex
because women want a commitment so and
women they wouldn't give sex unless
there was a commitment and then they
want someone that can cook and clean and
maintain a home that's good with
children and a lot of women don't want
children
um and they they wanted Purity like they
wanted a virgin and women aren't virgins
anymore and then add the divorce courts
on top of that I mean and then and then
as a society as well like there's no
shame with divorce it almost seems like
a life milestone at this point it's
really sad and so now there's divorce
parties yeah yeah what there's women
throw parties when they get divorced oh
my God this is just yeah it's absolutely
absurd I just like as a like as a
Christian though I really think like if
there are
if there's like structures in place and
you're clear and and you you I guess
it's hard right because like I you a
woman can I don't know like watch I
don't know she can watch like Rollo to
Massey and she can like be singing his
praises and saying exactly what you want
to hear get the ring and then gain like
50 pounds and sit on her behind and then
take you for half if you leave and like
not give you sex yeah that's what that's
what women do a lot of them they get the
this is like I I have men I had this guy
he sent me this long email and it was so
sad it was like
um you know after watching your content
I think I was my wife's second choice
because
um after kids like I haven't slept with
her in two years and he's like I make
this much money I go to the gym I do
this I do this and I don't want to cheat
but I I feel I feel trapped in this
marriage and if I leave she's probably
gonna take a bunch of money but I would
say and he also was like I love her but
I like this I can't but I would again
like going back to what I said before oh
there's certain conditions that I go in
on and I'm very hard and fast on those
conditions if they're not met
then I'm out and if you take my money
all right I'll get more but I'm not
saying that to be arrogant like you got
to the place you got to right
and again you I don't I actually agree
with a lot of you you're probably
thinking what are you saying maybe
because you're saying there's no
incentive but you still want to do it
yeah like call me crazy but
in a way that kind of makes me want to
do it even more I'm I'm a bit extreme
that way like I'll take on the challenge
let's go you know not if red flags like
I don't know for me if there's red flags
clear red flags why are you going to get
married yeah if a woman's not connecting
to a man I agree with you or a man's not
connecting to a woman why where is the
motivation to even think like I really
wanna I see this as a long-term thing I
agree with you that's what I'm saying
though like as long as the criteria are
met for me and are still met like I
would say to him I I would I always say
some like my friends I'm brutally honest
with them you know if they tell me like
they want to lose weight I just say like
move more eat less work out what you
need to do to to do that right and make
it easier for yourself
and I think it's the same I think when
it comes to relationships I think it
helps both men and women to take the
emotions out of it and think as
robotically as possible these are my
requirements if my requirements are not
met I am gone that is it and I think
another thing is women would have a lot
more respect for their men if the man
had principles and stuck by them I agree
so if they go in and say these are what
my expectations are right okay she takes
some of your money okay she takes the
kids you're gone right she might
actually have the most respect she's had
for you in years if you actually leave
I think if that that guy that sent you
that email she might actually respect
him for the for the first time maybe
ever if he left no I agree I think women
take advantage of men that they know
that they can yeah definitely and
um
yeah and that's the that's the crazy
thing is I I had a clip um go go viral
like a couple months ago where I just
said if your girl gains a hundred pounds
before she's even had kids like you can
leave you don't have to put up with that
and it's like I had all these wait like
these girls coming out my page and it's
like if he if he dates you and you start
overweight okay fine he's into bigger
girls but like you're selling a guy 120
and now you're 220 that's not fair yeah
and I also feel like guys get shamed too
for like dumping their girlfriends which
is the opposite for women at least from
my experience yeah like from what I see
yes you go girl it's like but he was a
great guy why would you leave him
well it's it's like a weird complex like
women were always like go out of their
way to tell you when they have a toxic
ex and oh like I've had so many girls on
my show say oh I had this a toxic
abusive this this X and it's just to the
point where I sometimes question The
credibility because I've just had so
many people do it and men don't don't
come forward like that if anything like
I've had guys pull me aside after the
show and tell me a story but they don't
come on usually I do agree with that I
do agree with what you're saying but I
do feel like is it feel as though
men because sex is so accessible they
don't have to treat you that well
because they know they've conquered you
they know that they're bonded to you
like like if when a woman has sex with a
guy she's bonded to the guy so well then
girls wouldn't leave girls leave 70 to
80 of the time well yeah I guess that's
true but sometimes they're leaving for
someone else well sometimes you know
it's another guy that they're pursuing
for whatever reason an ex-boyfriend so
sometimes it's not for those but my
thing is like I just don't think we
should believe women without evidence
and if you haven't pressed charges like
I'm sorry I don't know you like you need
to press charges and like if somebody's
punching me in the face I would press
charges I don't understand why you
wouldn't it's easier said than dancing
it's it's not necessarily for women for
women for women it's pretty easy the
Law's on your side for men it's not it's
harder for men but sometimes it can be
hard like you can't I feel like those
are subjects you can't really speak on
because mentally you you're what if that
guy mentally breaks you down to a point
where he says that boom if you go to the
police oh no like you just can't speak
on certain things like that like it's
easier said than done like it takes it
will take up a lot for women to pick up
that courage to leave somebody that's
mentally abuse them and physically abuse
them and control them to a certain
extent where they're even afraid to but
I think my thing is women will go on
public platforms and destroy a man's
reputation they know yeah I feel like
that so I'm saying like if if you're not
willing to go to the police and you come
on a public platform where people know
you they know who you dated it's not
fair that we just believe them if they
didn't if there's no evidence it should
be innocent improved yeah everything
yeah and so it's like I I think you
should press charges if that happened
okay and if not you're going to go on a
public platform and destroy a man's
reputation without any like evidence I
can't just believe you if I don't know
you
I guess it's a society we live in now
like Council culture they feel like
sometimes it's easier to go online and
do that you get a better result by doing
that because I had to look at it at one
time like why wouldn't you rather just
go to the police rather than you coming
online doing it but I guess now it's
like Council Court choice is easier but
the ones that are coming with fake
stories and I'm just like well I don't I
don't know what's fake and what's real
but it it seems disingenuous to me if
you're coming if you're too scared to go
to police but you're brave enough to
come and tell talk about it on my back
okay yeah so yeah
like that's I'm not saying like some
women
um aren't scared to go to police I know
that happens but it's just like it's
it's odd to me yeah yeah sorry I
misunderstood no no it's you're okay
you're okay I I know that um
you know I'll be like but the other
thing that's crazy about abuse is
actually the majority of the time um
they're hitting each other and that's a
lot of times girls like they forget to
talk about this where the majority of
abusive relationships are both hating
each other so they'll say oh I was
abused and I'll be like okay did you hit
him yes so you were abusing each other
but what you saw Advantage yes because
yeah lose loser for us in this country
so if I say he was beating me up two
minutes ago people are gonna believe
that mm-hmm that they're going to
believe it because I'm a woman and also
that's the disadvantage I'm a female so
that's not a good thing but
unfortunately a lot of women do use it
to their advantage though yeah and you
can hit first and then women always do
yeah and and then he hits you back and
now you're the victim it's like um the
if it's one-sided abuse 70 of the time
it's a woman hitting a man and not vice
versa and so knowing these stats and
when I come on these platforms like I'm
like why
why don't I have men coming forward as
much as women and the only the only
times I do it's usually like in DMS or
like messages
yeah it's like that guy that reached out
to you he I think he would
that's the first step man like be open
you you you will grow if you're if
you're willing to do it yeah what did
you say back to him
did you reply
I get a lot of tea okay
I get I get so many sometimes it's like
overwhelming I read a lot have you ever
had one where you did reply and you
remember or no yeah I've replied to a
couple
um there is one guy who told me like
basically that it was really sad like
this was one of the saddest DMS I've
ever gotten like basically he's never he
was like addicted to hookers and he's
never had a girl like interested in
having sex with him ever and he's like I
got in shape I did this I did this and
like no but not anymore now then now
like it was like two years later he's
addicted to Corn hooker like you know
like bad bad stuff and I was just like
damn that would never happen to a woman
not not in the same way you know because
like women always have someone that
wants to sleep with them always for the
most part and so it's like I feel like
there's a level of loneliness that women
just don't understand or like we will
never understand because like I don't
think that would ever happen to me or
any woman I know
it was really sad it is sad but it
I do believe there's a way out for a lot
of guys I I do that's that's why I
responded I was like okay you should try
this this and that but then I was like
I'm Despair and I'm like okay I don't
know how else yeah
like I don't know how else to help you
I'm like trying to give you some thank
you
the the
modern dating yeah
I think the laws have to change that's
what I think I think if we want to
incentivize men to get married again the
laws have to change
um personally I feel like all the
problems would go with we got rid of
birth control but I don't see that
happening I think that's like the root
of everything
yeah I think that's part of it but go
ahead
oh gosh what do you think
so happy my face is covered I think
women they either need to lower their
expectations or get out of the workforce
okay that's a good one because if they
lower their expectations and their the
income of a man is not
um it doesn't need to be higher then I
think that's great but I think once they
leave the workforce they'll have a lot
more options
um
what's that word that they use like when
the man makes more hypogamy yeah yeah
they'll be more hypergamous that way
I think they still have to be able to
submit to a guy that makes less yeah
there are powerful CEOs that still come
home and submit to their husbands yes
yes like you think you think that
Supreme Court Justice in the U.S I
forget her name
um but she's like super accomplished I
guarantee she comes home she's like a
four or five kids yeah she's really
pretty yeah yeah you know what I'm
talking about like ABC or something or
ACB I can't remember her name off the
top of my house she's pretty yeah yeah
yeah she I'm like she she comes home
home and submits even though she's more
accomplished than her husband but it's
interesting because on this show like
I'll ask girls like how much would a guy
have to make for you to quit your job
for him and it's always like top 10
percent yeah but it's kind of like in
the 1950s like a guy made if a guy made
like like a like a living like the
equivalent of like minimum wage it was
still more than what she was making so
it would be normal for her to to want to
submit to that if she's not bringing
anything in but it's like we've come to
a point where like no one's no one's
talking about like how like we can't
keep going like this like like women say
they want a guy that makes more than why
are you like saying that women need to
chase the bag like yeah it doesn't make
any sense like numbers wise right right
what do you think
um is the solution to Modern dating
um
I would say submission number one
understanding submission
and communication I feel like women can
still work and submit to their husband
and still add more and be able to submit
because God forbid you're married and
your husband is sick and he's the
breadwinner and even if for example
you're not out working but he's making
money and you have your own little side
hustle or something just as long as
you're getting some sort of income
that's very important because as I said
before the woman is a helper how are you
gonna help your husband in that time
you're eventually gonna have to go out
and work and in that moment
it's a moment where women can get
big-headed like okay cool I'm the head
of the house now I'm making all the
money I'm supporting you but once you
submit and understand that you're here
to help and it's only for a short period
of time then yeah I think that
submission understanding each other's
roles in a relationship communication
also
lowering your standards a little bit
sometimes not expect like why would you
ask a guy to have this this and that and
you barely have nothing to amount to
that like come on be realistic like
Diane you make 25 000 a year you want to
make six figures you get me like it does
not make sense Diane
it does not make sense but yeah that's
what I think okay go ahead yeah I think
to to just piggyback off of that I think
flipping the whole idea of settling
right because if you ultimately want to
be with a man right if you're uh
Sleeping with a bunch of guys who are
you know the top 10 you know the top of
the top but none of them want to commit
to you I see that as settling because
all you're settling for is sleeping
around if you want a long-term
commitment
and I will also speak from a guy's
perspective because we are playing the
game we're playing
you gotta play it man you gotta level up
so like that's what I've done in my life
and try to continue to do I know it does
work it does work and I do think like I
just said like just being realistic you
know if and the last thing is to tie in
with being realistic I think we should
communicate more about body clock
because I don't think a lot of people
know this
about you know losing I think it's
losing 90 of your ninety percent of your
eggs are gone by 30 by 30. like
as so many geriatric pregnancy starts at
35 and if you want to do that you have
to have twenty thousand dollars of cash
like ready to go and it might not even
work like what if you had that one I
know this sounds crazy but imagine it
was on a dating app like you set up a
profile and it goes what do you want I
want marriage okay how old are you cool
this is your probable biological clock
maybe you should go get your eggs
checked because that's actually what you
want you don't want to date around and
sleep with a bunch of guys because
that's actually you've just answered the
form do you know what I'm saying yeah
like because a lot of times I think
like women will be like I'll have girls
in my show they'll be like 30 31 32 and
it's like if you want to have kids you
like how long are you going to date the
guy before you have kids and it's like
you might want to get in like they're
still oh I'm having fun like I don't
know what you know and it's like okay
you know time's ticking
um yeah it's true because I've got a
friend who's out there in the streets
dating in their 40s and she's enjoying
the dating experience
but as I said to her you kind of past
that really you've got to know what you
want how to get it yeah and I think
women really sometimes don't know we're
full of contradictions we say we might
want a dating experience but at the same
time we're thinking about a lifetime
partner but how do you get that through
just doing that yeah I mean being
serious about it yeah and I think we
mean sometimes we can fluctuate
sometimes we want a man sometimes we
don't sometimes we just
because we're not getting what we want
we we then
add other things onto the list of things
that I'm not getting and the reason why
I'm not getting that would you ladies in
the room if you knew that stat ahead of
time would that have changed your dating
choices
so I'm assuming you didn't know that
stat maybe you did but I didn't know
that stat I knew that they you lost your
eggs over time but I didn't know it was
as bad as that so do you think it would
have maybe changed your dating choices
if you knew that
I could be wrong
not really okay it might make people
desperate though yeah making the wrong
decisions I feel like okay I feel like
if knowing what I know now why would I
date an ex if I knew it wasn't gonna
work out I wasn't gonna end up with that
guy yeah like if I could go back and I
know okay that like that guy that
wouldn't work with that guy that's what
I'm saying I'm like if I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna waste my time okay this guy's
yeah he's fine that comes down with like
just knowledge over time because if you
look at it we're younger do you get me
those relationships taught me a lot to
wear
whereas if I had known about my body
body clock
um if I had had a child when let's say I
got pregnant around 20 I wasn't ready
then I knew I was not ready then the guy
that I was with then he was not ready I
would have brought a child into a world
where they would have suffered they
would have have had the best and I know
for myself I I want my child to have the
best and I wouldn't want to bring my
child into an environment environment
where it's toxic I'm not with the dad or
I'm struggling and stuff like that I
would don't want that for myself to get
me I'm not where I want to be in life
yet so why would I want to bring a child
into it like this immature girls I've
had children and you see that how they
are with their children you know so yeah
I know some people I won't say who close
to me that
they chose to keep their baby and it and
they did everything in their life for
that baby and it made them level up so
they didn't have the perfect situation
and
like you say there's there's trauma
there and there's this and that but they
used to do shotgun weddings
they used to do shotgun weddings so like
like the
I mean you've never heard that term you
don't have the hair it's like basically
like the girl gets knocked up and the
dad takes a shotgun and says marry my
daughter and people and like I know a
lot of like people that are their 60s
and 70s and like they're still married
they just figured out a way to make it
work and even even my mom um she got
pregnant when she was 17 and she gave
that kid up for adoption and then she
ended up having nine more kids and they
started a multi-million dollar business
it doesn't mean your life's over yeah
it's because you're a kid you know
before you're ready
yeah sorry I interrupted you though no
no no that was that was the end of my
point
um okay well I'm gonna Read Super chats
one more time and then we're gonna close
out the show
um this was a fun one I think we lost
someone sorry super chats can
um you know and I warned you guys but
guys I always warn people before the
show about the Super Chat I love this
game I always I always warn I can't okay
Andrew Cruz um people used to have kids
before they were ready all the time it
was fine as long as they stuck together
see brown I believe it's a cop-out a few
actually get the opportunity to complain
because the guy is controlling AKA he
has expectations The Savvy ninja money
alone will not save a marriage meet the
wealthiest women in the world all
divorced from billionaires yet some
peasants are happy for Life JC that's
true money doesn't buy happiness um JC
the guy's girlfriend sitting behind the
camera whispering to herself saying got
his ass while rubbing his hands together
like Birdman she's been doing that the
whole time
mgtow by Logic um the higher her
standards the more she expects a man to
settle make it make sense marriage
causes divorce marriage so dangerous
prenups have to had to be in marriage is
so dangerous that prenups had to be
invented marriage causes divorce women
in the UK are incentivized to get
divorced the walk away with 70 and the
house the guy will have to start over
and move back in with his parents silly
sausage today's modern dating is just
practicing divorce date date then sex
then leave rinse and repeat everyone
wants fast results relationships take a
lifetime of hard work my grandparents
were married for 70 years mgtow by Logic
there are no Solutions only risk
mitigation
dread game never stop betting be the
best you can be Embrace a spirit of
giving and tell the truth drazian gaming
for from the streets did she emerge into
the streets has she returned goodbye
Oscar Grouch big Breezy um thoughtimus
Prime just left like that that's crazy
Arthur venegis body count matters I
dated a girl in college and met new
classmates that made fun of me because
the girl I was with went to a party in
blue for God Jesus okay it was
embarrassing it matters love you Pearl
keep hustling before
four four well what are y'all be doing
in these three that's crazy that's um
please take Clips off your main channel
it's tough sifting through the clips to
find your full podcast
we're working on that soon soon
um and it doesn't make sense to have
especially since you have two clips
channels Alexander affleo please don't
encourage women to go into martial arts
young men need their own space to become
men women interrupt the process too late
I already know I already know marriage
causes divorce why the hell would men
marry if he's going to lose 70 in
divorce marriage rates in the UK are
also at its lowest rate guys wake up
don't do it mgtow by Logic hypergamy is
necessary unchecked hypergamy destroys
everyone and everything Joseph Metzler
um social media is how most people get
attention follower counts likes Etc as
how most people Flex keeps keeping
socials is the same as trying to get a
number just to see if you can't oh
that's an interesting comparison that is
a good point that is a
oh my that's kind of what I was getting
at is I think a lot of people flip girls
and guys even girls I think do it when
they don't need to they they Flex just
to know they've still got it you know
like because I always ask people why
have you got social media
mm-hmm are you trying to produce
anything no so you're just consuming are
you learning anything from it no I just
watched cat videos okay fine but
what are you really getting from it and
I can say this because I deleted all my
social media before setting it back up
to grow my my businesses and stuff so
you don't why do you need it if you're
in a long-term relationship you're not
producing anything you're not learning
anything from it why do you actually
need it that's a really good equivalent
like social media versus a guy going up
to a yeah yeah that's a really good
equivalent because you've got you get
likes every day what does the guy get
word like DM yeah your DMs yeah yeah
yeah that's a good equivalent um JC and
deal here's tan The Savvy ninja so you
come home from work you both share your
day he proceeds to tell you that three
different girls flirted with him or hit
on him during the day rather he say that
or it was just a boring day at work
um so I just don't want to know Silly
sausage example of why girls getting
numbers wanting to see it if they still
have it perfect you said it's all
disrespectful it's all you guys do on
Instagram and relationships constantly
owned by your own logic
um K summers8404 I flexed on my wife
then that a girl asked me out she
informed me that three men had asked for
her for her number both at the same bar
at the same time Alexander aflo ninja
girl knows what's going on we need more
women like her and yes we have strayed
from the judeo-christian values that's
why we are more miserable nowadays
because we lack purpose too much Choice
um Balboa can we get a 360 from Pro stop
it no
um osmosis reacts simping and its finest
even when women don't even women know
it's gross
and then Pearl's mic is peeking we read
that one I'm gonna refresh it really
quick as like the video while you're at
it for we should have a thousand likes
in here we've had a thousand people in
here over a thousand the whole time we
don't have a thousand likes like let's
let's get it going also leave a comment
and um subscribe while you're at it okay
I'm gonna read the rest
um jb737 Scottie Pippen's wife recently
divorced him all these wife celebs are
leaving them thinking the grass is
greener on the other side what chances
does an average guy have going on with
all that kill on I actually okay just
quick sidebar I actually think it's
harder for celebrities because like
those women are in circles with all
these other high value men that they can
get attention from like I I think it's
like they're kind of at a disadvantage
because even like look at Jeff bezos's
girl like she's not leaving for better
than Jeff Bezos like Leonardo DiCaprio
is a wife and her but she was still
flirting with him in front of her man
yeah and like normal people aren't in
those situations so I I think they're at
a disadvantage
um Killen Daniels it's my birthday 32
glad to be here for the first live show
for me the UK Economist there's going to
be an epidemic of single older people
being homeless what are the low earners
going to do if they're unmarried Andrew
Cruz people used to have kids before
they were ready all the time okay we
read that one okay so um why don't we go
around
um tell the people where they can find
you tell you though many final thoughts
you have if there's anything you know
you want to speak your piece on now is
your time so go ahead
hi everyone
um you can find me on locals at Linda
alves.locals.com I'm going to be talking
about
um more traditionalism I share pretty
good memes and pictures of my face and
live streams and stuff
yeah if you want to know what she looks
like
I have a woke I have a really woke job
and awoke uh well not a woke job I I
work in a woke industry the Locust
industry in the world so I cannot say
that women should be in the home or that
would solve things in that industry go
ahead okay guys you can find me at Bella
taffa
b-e-l-l-a-t-a-f-a and also my business
um support with sister customized
clothes I clean shoes yeah and that's
cotton edges c-u-t-t-i-n-e-d-g-e
EZ and final thoughts you marry for
purpose that's my final thought you
marry for purpose
um yeah that's it really
thanks for having me on first of all and
uh you can find me at the geek physique
on pretty much every platform on
Instagram it's
d-o-s-s-i 9695 I run a free seven day
challenge for guys to master Their Food
Training and consistency in 10 minutes a
day so you're welcome we're we're
filling up the next challenge as we
speak
did you have something yeah I forget I
forgot to say you can find me on
Instagram and Tick Tock you want to put
in your username or did you already do
it I've already done it okay okay yeah
go ahead
no social media respect yeah don't need
it
um
I just want to say I think my last
thoughts are women should love
themselves love themselves not love
yourself through a partner boyfriend
girl from whatever just love who you are
and also go for what you want and be
consistent with how you are as well in
order for you to get the best out of
your life yeah okay thank you guys all
for coming this was a fun panel
um okay just couple announcements before
we end the show first off we got our
first live show with almost no issues
the new place shout out shout out
blessing he's been working hard
um he's camera shy but he's been working
so hard to get this set up so big up
blessing yeah yeah give it give him Bill
give round of applies
um okay so first of all guys like the
video on your way out that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out this content so if you think
that more people should watch the
channel you want to push out the content
a like is free okay it takes like two
seconds hit the like button on the video
on top of that if you've watched two or
more of my lives and you don't subscribe
we have beef okay sign up or subscribe
to our Clips channels
sign up next chat next live is going to
be members only so if you want to be a
part of the Chat sign up for the
memberships if you want to see first
behind the scenes look of the pet house
sign up for our 10 tier on that Vlog
will likely be posted maybe next week
um tier three we connect on social media
tier four
um you do one-on-one calls once a month
like a group yeah anyways we also do
members only live streams and we're
probably gonna do that in two weeks
follow my Instagram we're almost to 50K
just.pearly things also I have another
Tick Tock account because they took away
Tick Tock number one Tick Tock number
two Tick Tock number three so it's just
pearlythings dot four someone I don't
know who took who took the username just
probably things for but we have beef but
yeah just pearly things dot four
um let's get to 350 Subs Our member of
the week is Dragon stallion one zero
zero one dm Eddie if you want to come on
the show the link to his Instagram is in
the description thank you for watching
and we will talk to you next time name
bye